all right we're closing out the show
tomorrow's election day
not just about taxes they'll go up
higher oil gas
fossil fuels eliminate him trillions in
a new green deal it is important to keep
in mind joe and kamala harris
they will completely upend our system
starting with the us supreme court
and capitalism everything's free uh
taxes trillions of new dollars in taxes
by the way
packing the court biggest power grab
ever amnesty that is
vast ending the legislative filibuster
all of that is on the table law and
order is on the table
what are democrats going to do they're
not stopping there they want to expand
the u.s senate they're going to have
what two more senators from d.c two more
from puerto rico
you have democratic majority in
perpetuity and of course they want to
end
some of them even the electoral college
that's how extreme they are
amnesty for 15 million people also oh
free health care
now we have another generation of vote
for democrats because we give you
something of value
they don't care about your liberty they
don't care about your freedom these
radical socialists are about power
power over all three branches of
government power over major industry
power to destroy the entire energy
sector business
power in perpetuity no checks and
balances putting the constitution aside
one party rule in this country for
decades and decades to come
you've all been warned election day
voting is
critical for republicans in all of these
states
don't listen to the mob in the media
don't listen to pollsters
block out the noise and do your part
control what you can control
after four years of president trump you
know what to expect unlike most
politicians he kept his promises
he put on the supreme court justices as
promised
he lowered taxes he slashed regulations
he prison reform
uh criminal justice reform he killed the
caliphate baghdadian associates is dead
solomonia is dead
the ranking leaders of al qaeda dead
phased out the disastrous iranian
nuclear deal
he got us out of the paris accords no
more
cash loads of cargo planes of cash and
everything along with multiple middle
east peace to peace
deals even moved the embassy to
jerusalem with so many promise
then you got dr doom gloom and dark
winner joe biden
you think in between spoonfuls of
oatmeal and applesauce they would have
told them
the vaccine is just weeks away final
stage human testing
this country rests in your hands freedom
is one generation away from extinction
ronald reagan told us we just had a
whopping third quarter growth of 33.1
percent
i wish america i hope you make the right
choice tomorrow
our kids are counting on you it's all
the time we have left